terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait l'avoir années
70-80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des gourous faut plutôt
parler de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti
vaccins contre locaux vides certains
éléments qui se rattachent à des
mouvements à tendance sectaire qui
historiquement sont opposés à toute
vaccination
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le pass and i ter va-t-il être à
nécessaire pour se rendre au travail
pour elisabeth demande rien n'est acté
chanteau cas l'idée est sur la table et
elle a été discuté ce matin avec les
partenaires sociaux des syndicats plutôt
réticent à rendre de passes élitaire
obligatoire à l'ensemble de la sphère
professionnelle
le porte-parole du gouvernement estime
lui qu'il s'agit pour l'instant d'une
hypothèse
une association d'aidé aux migrants
dépose plainte contre le préfet maritime
et deux responsables des secours
français et britanniques une plainte
pour homicide involontaire et omission
de porter secours après le naufrage qui
a coûté la vie à 27 migrants fin
novembre dans la manche utopia 56 c'est
le nom de l'association elle souhaite
savoir pourquoi personne n a porté
secours aux migrants selon elle des
passagers auraient lancé des appels d'
alerte au secours français et
britanniques
et puis le président de groupe d'experts
des nations unies sur la guerre au yémen
a été espionnée grâce au fameux logiciel
pegasus c'est en tout cas ce que
révèlent les journalistes qui ont
dévoilé à l'immense opération
d'espionnage il estime également que
l'arabie saoudite pourrait être impliqué
dans cette affaire
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
rencontre ce matin entre le ministre la
ministre du travail et les partenaires
sociaux avec quelques jours de noël ils
ont évoqué ensemble la possibilité
d'imposer le pass sanitaire dans toutes
les entreprises du pays elle pour
elisabeth bornes rien est actée et
gabriela talent estime pour l'instant
que l'idée n'est qu'une hypothèse
les syndicats eux sont moins séduit par
l'idée les détails avec katia technique
samedi le ministre de la santé olive et
veyran à considérer le pass annie terre
pour aller travailler comme une option
d'ailleurs ce sera une proposition du
futur projet de loi présenté à
l'assemblée le 10 janvier prochain il ne
s'agirait pas d'imposer une obligation
vaccinale pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail mais a minima de pratiquer des
tests on ne peut pas empêcher les gens
d'aller travailler s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés mais on peut exiger d'eux
qu'ils passent un test s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés cela fait partie des questions
qui doivent être posées et la ministre
du travail elisabeth borgne s'est
acquitté de cette tâche en
visioconférence d'urgence avec les
partenaires sociaux ce lundi car il est
évident que cette mesure donnerait lieu
à de véritables casse têtes tout d'abord
il faudrait mettre en place des
contrôles dans certaines grandes
entreprises les arrivées sont déjà
filtré dans des sociétés de petite
taille qui devra s'acquitter de cette
tâche le pass annie terre existe déjà
dans le domaine de la restauration des
loisirs ou de la santé et c'est le
responsable établissement qui exercent
les contrôles certains dirigeants
pourrait y être opposés mais comment
contrôler un salariés en télétravail en
voyage d'affaires qui oeuvrent sur le
terrain ou au domicile de clients
patrick martin président délégué du
medef ex comme ses doutes le risque pour
le chef d'entreprise s'il ne fait pas
face à ses responsabilités
c'est 45000 euros d'amendé et un an
d'emprisonnement
elles sont chefs d'entreprise d'exercer
d'une certaine manière des pouvoirs de
police en s'exposant à des peines très
lourdes et quid des salariés s'opposant
à la mesure des sanctions seront elles
prises à ce sujet benoît sert le vice
président de l'association nationale des
drh laisse imaginer le pire pour les
employés refusant d'obéir à cette
disposition juridiquement je ne vois pas
comment on pourrait faire autrement on
n'a pas le droit de le contraindre à se
faire tester avoir un pass sanitaires à
ce jour par conséquent il faudrait
suspendre son contrat vous imaginez
l'ambiance dans l'entreprise en réponse
le salarié pourrait être mis en congés
être suspendue sans licenciements se
mettre en télétravail sachant que ce
n'est pas possible pour toutes les
professions ou encore pratiquer des
tests de kobe 19 régulièrement il
faudrait bien sûr déterminer combien de
temps le test négatif serait valide face
à tous ces écueils benoît sert propose
de le limiter aux lieux recevant un
grand nombre de salariés à la fois comme
le restaurant d'entreprise et autres
questions quid de la confidentialité sur
les données de santé en italie le pass
sanitaire a été imposée pour les
travailleurs avec suspension sans
licenciements et des amendes pour les
patrons qui ne respecteraient pas le
protocole 15 % des employés du privé et
8 % des travailleurs du public n'ont pas
de passes et en allemagne ce sésame est
obligatoire depuis le 18 novembre en
tout cas les grands syndicats s'opposent
à cette option françois omr il de la cfe
cgc pense que le passe au travail risque
de rencontrer une forme d'hostilité de
la part des salariés d'être contournée
fin de citation pour philippe martinez
secrétaire général de la cgt il faut
promouvoir les gestes barrière inciter
davantage de la vaccination plutôt
qu'instaurer se passe un projet absurde
et totalement inefficace selon le leader
syndical
un avis qu'on imagine partagée par de
très nombreux employés en france et on
continue de parler de la réunion ce
matin avec dany bouton membres du bureau
fédéral de la cgt santé
abdouni beau temps bon tour merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
j'imagine que vous avez suivi comme nous
ce qui s'est passé ce matin l'idée de
vacciner tous les salariés en france
qu'en pensez vous
s'était déjà exprimée par notre
secrétaire général
inez c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement absurde inefficace pourquoi
parce qu'on ne sort pas d'une crise
sanitaire d'un point de vue
philosophie d'un point de vue humain
avec une politique de coups de bâton des
salariés c'est déjà des professionnels
et donc des professionnels ils sont les
mieux à même de
mettre en application les gestes
barrières pour protéger soit les salles
les autres salariés et aussi le public
sur lequel ils peuvent recevoir donc
c'est infantile ise ces professionnels
et ça sera une mesure qui va être très
compliqué à mettre en place puisque qui
bat pas contre commencent à contrôler et
puis la question se pose c'est
le secret médical normalement c'est la
médecine du travail qui allie données
médicales des salariés là ça va être le
entreprises top et le responsable d'une
autre piste qui va avoir une données
médicales alors s'il porte ouverte pato
qui est requis et complètement
inadmissible et inacceptable et je
répète d'un point de vue démocratique
humains ils filent et aupic c'est pas
comme ça qu'on sort d'une crise quand il
ya une crise on sait que la meilleure
façon de mettre en place et de protéger
ses les est barrière nous au mois dans
le secteur de la santé 1 vous savez
depuis le 15 septembre une obligation
vaccinale le résultat de l'obligation
vaccinale c'est qu'un vingt mille
salariés va mille-îles agents du secteur
de la santé de l'action sociale ont été
suspendus de leur contrat de travail
20000 personnes qui sont plus au contact
des patients déjà on était en flux tendu
et en grand manque de personnel avec des
fermetures de lits des fermetures de
d'urgence et maintenant des directions
demanda les personnels salariés qui ont
qui sont positifs qui sont positifs au
co vide et quéau qui sont
asymptomatiques de venir travailler
puisqu'il n'y a plus assez de personnel
là vous voyez où est la logique où est
le bon sens le bon sens c'est avec du
recul on prend on prend on assume les
gestes barrières on laisse les salariés
à se vacciner puisque je rappelle que la
cgt on est pas on est pour la
vaccination on est contre cette
obligation vaccinale sais c'est
complètement différent il ya des
personnes qui kim qui ont besoin de plus
de temps pour se vacciner par rapport
aux par rapport au vaccin par rapport à
leurs risques par rapport à
à leur ressenti personnel puisque c'est
un geste médical et donc c'est pas avec
une politique de coups de bâton comme
celle là que l'on va avancer les choses
et au contraire on va mettre une grande
tension dans le milieu du travail
et ça c'est pas c'est pas acceptable de
nîmes temps pour l'instant les
organisations syndicales
semblent ne pas vraiment être séduites
par cette idée de vacciner tous les
salariés mais les organisations
patronales non plus est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose de rassurant pour vous de
voir que organisations syndicales et
patronales sont plutôt d'accord pour
l'instant sur le sujet
rassurant je dirais pas ça parce que ce
taux dépend du cas les points de vue de
chacun ce que j'entends les
organisations patronales disque pour eux
ça va être difficile de pouvoir
contrôler tout le monde nous d'un point
de vue syndical on dit que le droit du
travail la liberté de travailler et la
liberté en date pour son contrat de
travail de ne pas être obligé de prouver
qu'on est en bonne santé pour aller
travailler c'est normalement la médecine
du travail mais effectivement
c'est quand même quelque chose de
rassurant qu'il ya un consensus mais le
consensus il doit se faire avec
l'ensemble des salariés doit se faire
avec l'ensemble de la population pour
avancer dans cette crise va ça peut se
faire que comme ça et surtout pas en
divisant alors là sur ce sur ce point de
vue que les organisations patronales ne
soit pas nos positions nous prendre vous
parliez à l'instant de division
justement est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
sentez elle est salariée en tout cas
l'espérer vous connaissez divisés sur la
question de la vaccination
a tout à fait le banc d'autres secteurs
puisque je vous dis depuis le 15
septembre il ya une obligation vaccinale
on a ça a complètement divisé les
vacciner contre les non vaccinés c'est à
dire que ben ceux qui sont pas vaccinés
10 mais moi je veux je veux pas
déraciner pour l'instant parce que je
sens que bénéfice risque il est pas il
est pas suffisant en tant que
professionnel je estime qu'avec les
gestes barrière je peux protéger les
patients ceux qui sont vaccinées au
débat vaccine toi parce que nous on
n'est pas assez pour travailler donc il
ya eu des tensions et même dans la
société actuelle quand on entend c'est
une pression qui est mise sur les 10%
de la population qui n'est pas vaccinée
si on en est là il faut que le
gouvernement aille jusqu'au bout des
shoes
et que la cgt nous on a promis on a
promis la levée des brevets pour que non
seulement on vaccine un maximum de notre
population pour ceux qui le souhaitent
mais qu'on vaccine aussi les autres pays
qui n'ont pas accès au vaccin parce que
justement c'est un lobby vaccinale de
certaines de certains de certains
fabricants de vaccins et là ça c'est pas
acceptable c'est pas c'est l'ensemble de
la population mondiale qui doit avoir
accès au vaccin pour ceux qui le
souhaitent là on avancera mais il ya
besoin de beaucoup plus de discussions
de participation et surtout pas
d'opposition de passe de par opposer les
salariés vacciner les non-salariés les
longs ballons vacciner contre les
salariés ne pas diviser la population
entre ceux qui sont vaccinées ou pas
vacciné je reviens sur notre champ de la
santé dans la santé on a besoin de tout
le monde il nous manque quatre cent
mille emplois dans notre champ de la
santé et de la 2d secteur santé action
sociale 400000 emplois et le
gouvernement l'a suspendu vingt mille et
maintenant ils nous rappellent ils soyez
ferme des lits vous soyez rappel des
personnels asymptomatiques moi je prends
cet exemple là qui est criant donc il ya
suffisamment de division suffisamment de
tension les jeunes aussi une autre
jeunesse ou rendez compte à l'école avec
le pass l'obligation pour les autres
pour les enfants qu'elle qu'est-ce qu'on
comme on prend en compte notre jeunesse
qui a qui en adolescence qui à 18 ans
qui est jeune en ce moment et qui est
rentrer sur le mettre sur le champ du
travail qui est qu'à d'autres
obligations qui est martelé avec cette
crise là depuis plus du puy maintenant
désolé de vous couper malheureusement on
manque de sens merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du bureau
fédéral de la cgt santé merci encore une
fois
la décision est donc tombée aujourd'hui
après le conseil consultatif d'éthique
c'est au tour de la haute autorité de
santé de donner son accord pour la
vaccination des 5 11 ans contre le coc
vite 19 ont fait justement le point sur
les motivations et l'impact de cette
décision avec adrien fonteneau il y
avait déjà les enfants considérés comme
à risque il y aura désormais l'ensemble
des 5 11 ans dans un avis rendu ce lundi
la haute autorité de santé s'est montré
favorable à une vaccination étendue à
l'ensemble de cette tranche d'âge les
formes sévères de covile 19 affecte
rarement les enfants mais lorsque c'est
le cas près de 80 % d'entre elles sont
retrouvées chez des enfants sans
comorbidités par ailleurs dans le
contexte de l'arrivée du variant mikron
plus contagieux que le variant delta on
peut donc s'attendre à une augmentation
des cas de formes sévères chez les
enfants dans sa formulation pédiatrique
adapter le vaccin présente une très
bonne efficacité contre les variants
majoritaire circulant actuellement et sa
capacité à prévenir les formes sévères
et excellente
priorité de la haute autorité de santé
les collégiens de moins de 12 ans avant
d'entamer la campagne des 5 11 ans en
tout ils sont plus de 5 millions à être
concernés par cette vaccination non
obligatoire et une nouvelle stratégie
qui interroge quand 9% de la population
éligible n'a toujours pas reçu une seule
dose on sait que le virus circule chez
les enfants qu'ils ne risquent pas grand
chose parce que les formes graves sont
rares et les études produite jusque là
montrent que le vaccin n'a pas d'effets
secondaires significatifs chez eux pour
l'instant c'est rassurant mais on va
faire peser sur les enfants le poids des
adultes qui refusent la vaccination
donc même s'il n'ya pas vraiment de
risque sur le plan intellectuel il y a
quelque chose qui me choque dernier avis
attendu celui du comité d'orientation
pour la stratégie vaccinale en cas
d'autorisation
olivier vers en espère un début de
campagne d'ici mercredi après-midi
et pierre tattevin infectiologues et
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses du chu de rennes estime
qu'il est important de commencer à
vacciner les enfants est vraiment deux
bonnes raisons de le faire la première
c'est que quand même les enfants l'air
beaucoup plus sensible aux qu'ovide avec
les nouveaux variants le delta et puis
l'eau mikron qui arrive derrière on a
l'impression que ça circule beaucoup
plus ya les enfants que ce qu'on
connaissait avec les variants antérieur
et puis quand même c'est vrai que c'est
quand même une partie de la chaîne de
transmission pour les adultes les
personnes âgées pour les fermetures des
écoles tout ça fait que si on peut
diminuer la circulation du virus chez
les enfants ça sera pas une mauvaise
chose
et ailleurs pour contrer la propagation
du virus la suisse durcit ici
restrictions sanitaires est depuis
aujourd'hui l'accès à l'intérieur des
restaurants des établissements culturels
ou tout autre événement en intérieur est
interdit aux non vaccinés autre mesure
la limitation des réunions à 10
personnes et si l'une d'entre elles
n'est pas vaccinée la suisse qui a passé
depuis une semaine le seuil défini comme
critique des 300 malades en soins
intensifs à des nouvelles mesures
restrictives que condamnent ariel b
rastignac spécialistes en santé publique
à genève
toutes ces mesures sont ne sont que des
illusions de contre de l'épidémie mais
pas du tout de méme elle ne contrôle
rien du tout quand on sait que les laits
le virus circule aussi bien chez les
personnes vaccinées que chez les
personnes non vaccinées pourquoi
ostracisés et discriminer les personnes
non vaccinées comme si c'était elle qui
propager la maladie un vaccin n'est pas
une baguette magique que deuxième nombre
les vaccins
ne ne permettent pas de lutter contre la
contre la contamination s'agit de
défaire individuelle et donc on luttera
pas contre la quant au fait mal a dit
uniquement avec les vaccins
une association d'aidé aux migrants
porte plainte pour homicide involontaire
et omission de porter secours une
plainte contre le préfet maritime de la
manche et deux responsables des secours
français et britanniques elles selon les
témoignages de deux rescapés des secours
ont tardé à réagir malgré les appels
téléphoniques des passagers le naufrage
du 24 novembre dernier et coûté la vie à
27 exilé en majorité des kurdes irakiens
et qui tentait de rallier les côtes
anglaises
et puis henry président de l'association
france fraternité ça lui ce dépôt de
plainte et appelle à l'ouverture de
voies de migration légale pour éviter
d'autres drames il faut faire la lumière
sur l'ensemble du processus évidemment
sur les personnes qui ont des
responsabilités
dans le fait d'armer des bateaux de
battre une quarantaine de personnes de
prendre de l'argent mais il est aussi
normal
d'enquêter pour savoir si les
défaillances du système de secours et si
ces défaillances ont été volontaires il
faut que la grande bretagne prennent sa
classe je rappelle que les personnes qui
réussissent la traversée de la manche et
qui
arrivent sur le territoire britannique
par la mère dépose pour la plupart
d'entre eux 95 % une demande d'asile et
vous savez quoi près de 60 % d'entre eux
sont reçus sont éligibles à l'aise il
alors franchement ya sans doute une
autre méthode à employer
dans la sphère d'espionnage liés aux
logiciels israélien on apprend
aujourd'hui que le téléphone portable du
président du groupe d'experts des
nations unies sur le yémen a été
infiltrée c'est ce qui ressort d'une
enquête publique aujourd'hui par le
projet pegasus qui a réuni des
journalistes d'une quinzaine de
réactions internationales elle est
donnée suggère que à kamel j'aime doubi
a été pris pour cible par l'arabie
saoudite riyad utilisateur de longue
date du software et riadh sidaoui et le
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d'analysé politique et social pour
lui ces révélations ne sont pas une
surprise due au fait que l'arabie
saudite soit partie prenante du conflit
et may need
être espionnés par les sorguais sa
méthode pas parce que moi j'ai suivi ces
déclarations
donc certaines télévisions langue arabe
et les très critique vis-à-vis de la
situation des droits de l'homme et des
crimes commis par les saoudiens contre
la population civile yéménite et donc
c'est la revanche donc on ne vise 7
c'est compréhensible mais comme je dis
là les scandales c'est pour le monde
musulman et saoudiens qui se présente
toujours comme hal mais en israël mais
en réalité on sait bien que les
relations sont très présents
historiquement est aujourd'hui également
de l'écran noir en pologne où plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont manifesté hier
soir motif la nouvelle loi sur les
médias adoptée ce week-end par le
parlement lors d'un vote surprise le
texte empêcherait les entreprises
n'appartenant pas à l'espace économique
européen de détenir une participation
majoritaire dans un média polonais une
loi controversée qui vise le premier
groupe de télévision privé du pays
maxime hébert
volnay médias médias libres voilà ce que
scandaient les manifestants réunis dans
la capitale polonaise comme dans de
nombreux centres villes du pays ce
dimanche
citoyens et membres de l'opposition
étaient présents devant le palais
présidentiel pour protester contre une
loi jugée liberticide
[Musique]
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour
défendre la liberté des médias et la
liberté d'expression mais je voudrais
aussi que vous pensiez et que vous vous
rappeliez chaque jour de ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
parce que les prix élevés tu le budget
de leur ménage et de tous ceux qui sont
assis chez eux aujourd'hui
désespérés parce qu'il n'ya pas de place
dans les hôpitaux pour leurs proches
malades du code vide pour le
gouvernement ce texte protégerait le
paysage médiatique polonais contre des
acteurs considérée comme hostile le
sénat s'y étaient opposés après un
premier vote favorable de la chambre
basse du parlement la chambre basse qui
a confirmé son vote en deuxième lecture
ce vendredi le texte attend désormais la
signature d'andré fouda les manifestants
presse le président polonais à y mettre
son veto
c'est une tentative de bâillonner tvn
c'est principalement de cela qu'il
s'agit c'est la prochaine étape de la
construction d'un état autoritaire
ils font cela pour faciliter la victoire
aux élections
pour bâillonner les télévisions qui
surveillent leur arrière
dans le viseur de cette loi baptisée loi
tvn par ses opposants discovery
le groupe américain est propriétaire de
tvn premier acteur privé de la
télévision polonaise avec quatre chaînes
gratuites dont la principale chaîne
d'informations indépendantes du pays
depuis plusieurs années cette dernière
est considérée comme la plus critique
envers le pouvoir chaque jour 17
millions de polonais regarde au moins
une chaîne du groupe
nous n'avons aucun doute sur le fait
qu'il ne s'agit pas de réguler le marché
polonais des médias cette législation ne
vise qu'un seul diffuseur le groupe tvn
discovery si la loi entre en vigueur
notre propriétaire devra vendre une
partie de ses parts
cela signifie que les chaînes de tv n ne
pourront plus diffuser ce qu'elle
souhaite comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
les etats-unis se sont déclarés
extrêmement déçu par ce vote ils
réclament eux aussi le veto du président
du da dont le parti contrôle déjà la
télévision publique et une grande partie
de la presse régionale depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de son parti le pis la
pologne est passé de la 18e à la 64e
place dans le classement mondial de la
liberté de la presse
anthony si maintenant les mesures
exceptionnelles et président accueille
seyed continue de susciter la colère de
ses opposants de plus en plus nombreux
samedi un sit-in a rapidement été
interrompue par les forces de l'ordre
les activistes dénoncent des violences
policières et une atteinte à la liberté
de manifester
la correspondance à tunis deux bassins
chebbi
il avait attendu le week-end de la date
anniversaire de la révolution pour se
faire entendre mais leur action a
rapidement tourné à l'affrontement
samedi les membres du collectif citoyen
contre le coup d'état ont décidé de
prolonger les festivités avec la tenue
d'un sit-in pour dénoncer le coup de
force du président sayed du 25 juillet
dernier a exigé un retour à la
démocratie un sit-in rapidement maîtrisé
par les forces de l'ordre présentes sur
l'avenue habib bourguiba qui ont saisi l
les tentes et les chaises préparer pour
l'opération des heurts ont éclaté les
forces de l'ordre ont procédé à
l'arrestation de 12 militants pour
trouble à l'ordre public et outrages
suite à la tentative de certaines
personnes d'installer des chapiteaux sur
l'avenue habib bourguiba le samedi 18
décembre 2021 à 14 heures pour être
exploité dans le cadre d'un sit in en
violation de la loi des unités de la
sécurité civile sont intervenus pour
interdire une telle installation et
faire appliquer la loi il a été relevé
des agressions contre des cadres de la
sécurité civile une version réfutée par
les activistes qui dénoncent un
démantèlement sauvage et violent ou
encore des arrestations arbitraires pour
jaguar m barek chef de file du mouvement
elle l'exécutif et tout pour écarter
l'opposition ainsi que la société civile
il dénonce une violation des acquis
démocratiques de 2011 et exigent la
libération des militants arrêtés écoutez
le j'ai claire elle est claire
c'est à dire qu'à une sorte de
discrimination faite sorte de
discrimination entre le traitement des
manifestants et des manifestations pro
pouvoir proue ou des papes roux
président de la république en
contrepartie elle traitement
d'exclusion de discrimination de
violence contre à l'égard des
manifestants qui sont contre le coup
d'état ça s'est produit d'abord par
rapport au festin des parties de
joliette à cape town et c'est qu'ils ont
été exclus de l'avenue habib bourguiba
et aussi des manifestations qui ont été
organisées par citoyen contre contre le
coup d'état on demande au retour à
l'état de droit
l'arrêt des mesures d'exception et un
retour à l'état de droit depuis la sous
direction de la lutte contre la
criminalité de la garde nationale a
procédé à l'audition des activistes
interpellés pour outrages à agent dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions quant au
parquet de tunis il a ouvert une enquête
pour déterminer les causes exactes de
ces débordements
et bidons revu à la hausse
375 morts aux philippines la suite du
typhon rail est les opérations de
sauvetage se poursuivent alors que la
malaisie est également largement impacté
walid bennani
au pas de course des malaisiens plus que
jamais solidaires face à des phénomènes
climatiques imprévisibles
plus d'une vingtaine de milliers
d'habitants ont déjà subi de plein fouet
les fortes pluies aux conséquences
désastreuses
huit états dans le plus grand au centre
de la malaisie sont touchés les
principaux axes routiers du pays sont
bloquées
la capitale kuala lumpur également n'a
pas échappé aux inondations je pense que
je peux considérer ces inondations comme
une deuxième grande inondation à kuala
lumpur en 1971 il y a eu la plus grande
inondation à kuala lumpur donc
maintenant juste 50 ans après c'est un
désastre pour nous ça se passe dans
certaines maisons les gens à l'intérieur
sont déjà sortis mais il ya encore des
gens qui refusent de sortir ils veulent
rester au deuxième étage mais j'espère
vraiment que pour des raisons de
sécurité ils sortiront
d'autant qu'un certain malaisien
n'hésite pas à transporter à mains nues
un serpent le premier ministre très
actif sur twitter ces dernières heures a
également fait le déplacement pour
rencontrer les victimes il dit
comprendre leurs inquiétudes et leur a
promis une aide rapide en débloquant
enfants d'urgence de 21 millions d'euros
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une impression de fin du monde en
revanche de 1500 kilomètres plus loin
les philippins confrontée depuis
plusieurs jours un tifo mortel le plus
puissant répertoriées cette année
des vents atteignant 195 kilomètres à
l'heure des toits et poteaux électriques
arrachés des arbres déracinés
trois cent mille personnes ont déjà
évacuer leur domicile
je suis fatigué de regarder les
séquelles de typhons parce que c'est ce
que je vois toujours à chaque fois qu'il
ya un typhon je peux le constater et je
suis désolé pour les gens d'ici
20 ans pète tropicales aux typhons
s'abattent en effet chaque année sur
l'archipel asiatique dans un contexte
redoutait de changement climatique
les autorités philippines n'ont pas
manqué de mobiliser des milliers de
militaires garde-côtes ou encore
pompiers pour venir en aide à une
population dans le besoin
les sociétés de la croix-rouge et du
croissant-rouge ont lancé un appel pour
récolter plus de 19 millions d'euros
alors que les typhons rail se diriger
vers le vietnam ce dimanche
là c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes reste avec nous sur rt français
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ai des gants
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative en sort
du politique il est clair que tout le
monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant